quand vous dites je suis parti en
vérifiant tout vous deviez quand même
pas de radio de survie quoi ça c'est le
bateau coulé vous faisiez quoi
dans notre terrien du samedi 20h ce soir
Corentin Neuchâtel terrain bonsoir
alors Corentin à 25 ans alors que vous
connaissances sont navigation se
limitent à quelques ronds dans l'eau en
optimiste vous décidez de naviguer du
Bangladesh à La Ciotat à bord d'un
bateau que vous avez fabriqué vous-même
avec de la toile de jute alors au
département nous a pris pour un fou
désormais le monde de la mer vous
appelle le petit prince
[Musique]
Corentin rebonsoir vous êtes né à Vannes
dans le Morbihan le 14 mai 1983 père
notaire mère conseillère conjugal votre
famille habite à Muzillac un petit
village de la côte bretonne et vous vous
construisez les cabanes dans les forêts
des radeaux pour naviguer sur les
rivières enfance sympa ouais en pleine
campagne vous faites également des
stages d'optimistes mais n'oubliez pas
l'optimiste c'est un tiers du temps pour
mettre le matos dans l'eau interdit du
temps tu te fais engueuler par le mono
et un auteur du temps il faut ranger le
matos
[Rires]
alors justement le virus de l'aventure
vous l'attrapez à l'âge de 10 ans vous
partez passer vos vacances scolaires
chez un oncle qui habite en Guinée
Conakry et là vous passez vos journées
avec les gamins des rues vous jouez sur
une déchetterie vous récupérez tout ce
qui traîne pour fabriquer des jouets des
petites voitures la découverte là ce qui
est génial de d'arriver dans un pays
comme ça est aussi différent quand on
est gamin c'est qu'on n'arrive pas comme
un touriste et directement les gamins ce
qui vous font ça vous dit d'aller jouer
à la décharge bah ouais carrément et du
coup on a fait des espèces de camions
avec des boutons des bouts de branchage
et des bottes de conserve oui c'est de
là que date votre goût de la
récupération et du recyclage
alors pendant que vous allez des
étudiants votre seul obsession c'est de
voyager vous avez deux fois en Inde avec
une ONG au Paraguay en Uruguay en
Argentine en Éthiopie et un jour un ami
vous envoie une annonce Yves Marc
aventurier français cherche un
volontaire pour monter un chantier naval
au Bangladesh nourri logé vous partez et
sur le moment ça m'arrive super excitant
vos parents ils étaient contents de me
voir partir
alors là-bas au Bangladesh vous vivez
dans ce qu'on appelle la
construisez un bateau donc avec la récup
dans les chantiers
navalsitagonc dans le sud du pays c'est
là que viennent finir leur vie pas mal
de cargo et donc ils arrivent à fond à
pleine balle sur la plage il tente le
cargo sur la plage et donc il y a des
gars qui arrivent et qui creusent une
espèce de petite porte tout en bas du
cargo il rentre dedans il démonte tout
et j'ai pu récupérer pas mal de choses
pour équiper le bateau vous achetez un
moteur chinois de 8 chevaux ouais c'est
moteur qui utilise là-bas c'est ça se
démarre à la manivelle
finalement pour 7000 euros faites votre
bateau quoi bateau ouais alors reste un
détail à régler à prendre la navigation
j'ai fini par ça quand même non mais en
fait je connaissais la théorie et
ensuite
Yves m'avait expliqué ouais comment
est-ce que on mettait un point sur une
carte comment est-ce que tu gardes tout
ça et ensuite j'avais un peu réfléchi à
tous les problèmes qui pouvaient
m'arriver est-ce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe si le bateau se retourne aussi je
suis pris dans une tempête si j'ai plus
d'eau si j'ai plus de nourriture si je
tombe du bateau etc et j'avais une
réponse à peu près à chaque fois
et le 13 février 2010 vous partez du
Bangladesh direction La Ciotat dans
votre coque de noix alors avec des faux
papiers d'immatriculation vous n'êtes
pas non plus d'autorisation ben non
alors du coup quand on part pas avec des
vrais papiers enfin quand on fait des
faux papiers sur Photoshop on est obligé
de partir sans rien dire à personne
alors quelques heures après le départ
dans le delta du Gange il y a un premier
coup de vent et là le bateau est
carrément couché c'est il y a une grosse
barre de nuages qui arrivait du large
comme ça mais qui arrivait super vite et
moi rien n'était prêt je venais de
partir et surtout que je comptais bien
apprendre à naviguer les premiers jours
et théoriquement ça se passait bien ces
jours-là à la météo et en fait la barre
est passée et ça a vraiment couché le
bateau d'un coup et tout était en vrac à
l'intérieur je me suis retrouvé trempé
et avec un espèce de petit doute qui
naissait est-ce que ça va le faire alors
un mois plus tard vous pénétrez dans le
port de Gaulle point de sud du Sri Lanka
comme vous avez pas de document de
sortie de votre port d'origine c'est ce
qu'on appelle le port of clearens vous
êtes bloqué ouais ouais au final j'ai
payé je me suis cédé un backs chiffres
ou une amende mais on a réussi à
s'arranger ils ont vu que j'étais pas
vraiment un trafiquant de drogue
donc ça a été alors Sri Lanka votre
frère vous apporte un radeau de survie
parce que quand vous dites je suis parti
on vérifiant tout devient quand même pas
de radio de survie quoi chercher le
bateau coulé vous faisiez quoi il
restait quelques incertitudes
bon ensuite vous quittez le Sri Lanka
pour Oman alors là c'est donc la
presqu'île arabique un mois au milieu de
l'océan avec 5000 mètres de fond en
dessous quand on se baigne c'est
flippant non ouais ouais surtout qu'il y
a des requins dans le coin il fallait
que je nettoie la coque une fois par
semaine
et ouais au début ça fait un peu des
frissons dans le dos
alors vous mangez des nouilles chinoises
avec des champignons déshydratés des
boulettes de soja des épices beaucoup
d'épices vous fait toujours la même
chose mais en changeant les épices quoi
c'est un bon conseil que je peux te
donner tu devrais faire ça le même plat
en revanche la pêche vous y arrivez pas
du tout non étonné
[Applaudissements]
évidemment là-bas les pirates alors vous
avez pas d'armes en fait vous dites les
pirates ils vont venir sur le bateau
pour regarder manger et tout donc j'ai
des somnifères c'est vraiment je vais
mettre des somnifères dans la bouffe
pour endormir les pirates c'est Tintin
excusez-moi
est-ce que vous êtes bon c'est quand
même Tintin
[Applaudissements]
j'avais pas mal étudié les attaques de
pirates et effectivement ils mangent et
ils boivent à bord donc je disais
plutôt que de prendre une arme endormir
les pirates et les ligoter sur le mât ça
paraissait plausible mais sur place
c'était beaucoup moins
et puis d'un coup il y a des
hélicoptères de militaires hollandais
qui qui arrivent en fait ils font partie
d'une mission européenne contre la
piraterie il vous disent faites
demi-tour je pouvais pas faire demi-tour
parce que le vent allait dans tel sens
et voilà c'était impossible et puis ça
faisait trois semaines déjà que je
navigue
alors il vous disent quand même écoutez
faites attention
surveillez l'horizon et baisser les
voiles si vous voyez un autre bateau et
donc vous passez une semaine à scruter
l'horizon comme ça à la fin vous avez
les yeux complètement brûlés évidemment
[Musique]
ça le semaine vous dites je traversais
le territoire des pirates à la vitesse
d'une trottinette
mais sur les six mois la moyenne de
vitesse c'était ça ouais 7 km/h je crois
alors ensuite votre frère vous rejoint
un nouveau pour traverser la Mer Rouge
alors là vous apportera parce qu'il est
encore plus mauvais que vous en
navigation votre frère
pas terrible
un peu de recettes de cuisine et là il y
a des grosses grosses vagues vous testez
la résistance de votre invention et un
petit bateau comme ça c'est dans des
creux de 3 mètres c'est assez
impressionnant alors ensuite c'est le
canal de Suez alors le canal Suez ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir faire marche arrière donc votre
bateau il a pas de marche arrière donc
vous bricolez un truc vous êtes vraiment
bon pour que le bateau puisse faire
marche arrière et en fait j'avais déjà
vu au Bangladesh des moteurs comme ça
temps en temps par erreur le truc
démarrer à l'envers et du coup je me
suis dit mais ça se trouve ça peut
marcher alors c'est super dangereux pour
le moteur ça peut tout casser mais j'ai
fabriqué une manivelle pour pouvoir le
démarrer à l'envers et j'ai fait venir
deux fois l'ingénieur ça marchait pas et
la troisième fois mon frère essaye et
paf ça marche alors en fait les
autorités découvrent vous avez de faux
papiers heureusement vous êtes sauvés
par le directeur du Yacht Club de Suez
en fait il a peut-être eu peur que mon
bateau pourriez dans son lieu de club et
il a téléphoné au patron du canal de
Suez qui a dit bah oui on peut passer
alors vous avez payé pour traverser le
canal de Suez c'est quand même le
passage le moins cher de tous les temps
quoi non pour eux c'était un record
ensuite la Turquie la Grèce l'Italie et
le 17 août 2010 après 6 mois de
navigation en solitaire sur votre coque
en toile de jute vous arrivez à La
Ciotat vous venez de parcourir Corentin
14000 km
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la jute a tenu ouais mission accomplie
mais tout ce qui est juste alors le 15
septembre suivant vous présentez votre
bateau au public et aujourd'hui vous
avez prêté une copine pour traverser
l'Atlantique ce bateau il y en aura fait
j'ai eu la chance de trouver quelqu'un
capucine qui a pu reprendre le bateau et
elle elle a pu continuer à faire vivre
le bateau en traversant l'Atlantique
avec et donc là le TaraTari qui est
parti du Bangladesh et en Martinique
alors voilà vous avez construit ensuite
un deuxième bateau toujours en jute qui
s'appelle le Gold of Bengal alors là
vous voulez travailler l'autonomie
c'est-à-dire que dans ce bateau il y a
une serre pour les légumes un poulailler
pour les œufs ce qui fait que tu peux te
balader bouffer pendant des mois et des
mois et des mois en théorie en théorie
non parce que justement le but c'était
d'expérimenter tous les systèmes qui
mélangent high-tech et low tech en fait
c'est à dire essayer de faire pousser
des légumes sans terre en aéroponie
c'est à dire qu'il faut réussir à créer
un engrais la base de Furnes de poule
d'urine d'algues dose de poulet concassé
etc pour réussir à donner tout ce dont
la plante a besoin et vu vous avez créé
une association pour des projets à base
de jus pour que les paysans du
Bangladesh continuent en produire vous
êtes génial Corentin vraiment vraiment
c'est l'illustration de ce que disait
Gandhi ouais un arbre qui tombe fait
beaucoup de bruit mais une forêt qui
pousse le fait en silence et ça c'est
des forêts qui poussent partout de gens
qui ont plein de initiatives c'est
vachement bien je souhaite à tous
Corentin et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de Inna larditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu